[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to talk about
the fight between logan paul and floyd
money mayweather i don't know if you
watched it it was on at 4 00 a.m
this morning and i got up ridiculously
early to watch the fight
and the result was that there was no
winner and there was no loser it was
kind of a strange it wasn't even a fight
it was technically an
exhibition so logan is now saying that
he won
and floyd is saying that he could have
knocked him out if he'd really wanted to
but he was kind of just having fun to
get the people on the show
and he was fighting to survive as you
guys can see
but the bottom line is that logan paul
held his own as a 20-something year old
big guy but fighting somebody who beat
conor mcgregor a year or two back and
has
never lost a fight and has won 50 fights
in a row so
why am i talking about this on my
youtube channel well because
i'm really interested in what happened i
thought it was a really interesting
exhibition and i think there's some good
lessons
for business entrepreneurs and even
property investors in the fight
and the run-up to the fight so i'm going
to talk through what happened in my
opinion from my experience and also draw
some lessons but i'd also
love to know what you think who did you
think was gonna win
and who do you think did win because
it's completely ambiguous
i'll tell you what i thought was gonna
happen i thought that
logan paul was gonna get his ass
whooped by floyd i was really rooting
for floyd and the reason was is because
floyd
is a boxer that's what he does that's
all he knows
and i thought for floyd to lose would be
a little bit embarrassing
but then at the same time would it
because logan is a ripped
strapping six foot two twenty something
year old
fighting floyd who is in retirement
seeing them
face to face that that before the fight
kind of looked like david and goliath
and it physically looked like logan was
goliath
but actually everybody knew that really
floyd mayweather was
goliath because he is a boxing giant
he's a
world champion he has never lost
so what happened in the fight well what
happened was
it went eight rounds and that's that was
the total amount of rounds that was
agreed
and logan held his own logan got some
good punches in
he seemed a bit a little bit tired
around about round four but his stamina
just went on and on and on
and he held his own and floyd mayweather
said that he was impressed he said that
he'd underestimated
logan i mean mike tyson pryor had said
that
logan was gonna get his ass whooped
everybody thought that was gonna happen
but it didn't
logan shocked the world by holding his
own
in a ring for eight rounds with the
world
champion floyd mayweather so what are
the lessons here's the biggest lesson
i think logan paul is a youtuber
he's a youtuber he's not a boxer he's
not a fighter he's only had one fight
prior in his life and that was against
ksi who's also a youtuber
so how on earth did he hold his own
against floyd mayweather who yes he's in
retirement but also
he you know beat conor mcgregor up
recently so
how did he do it and here's how i think
he did it i think that sometimes
years of experience can be
a little bit over rated in business and
in anything if you
train relentlessly and
have i work hard and have belief it's
incredible what a year's worth of
training can do
and logan did exactly that he spent a
year training
getting ripped and that one year of
training and hard work and belief
as well in the ring meant that he could
hold his own against the giants
and why should that be encouraging to
you watching this video because
probably to you i am a property giant
i've been in the game now 12 years i've
done over 300 property deals
you might see me and think oh he's a
property giant you know i could never be
like that i could never be
as successful as as i am and
the bottom line is many of my students
after 12 months only of being in the
business
and working hard can hold their own
with giants in the business and property
space a lot of my students have become
my
peers within a year or two so
in the same way that logan paul i think
i think it's people massively
underestimate what you can do in 12
months
they might overestimate what you can do
in a week you might see the seven day
financial freedom challenge and then
samuel became financially free in seven
days on a challenge and then you'll have
a batch and
then have a crash and then feel
disheartened but i promise you this
if you dedicate 12 months
to going full out training
working hard and believing that you can
do it
you will be flabbergasted at how well
you can hold your own
in the business realm of real estate and
property investing
in just 12 months we'll be sparring not
in the boxing ring but we'll be doing
deals together
you'll be making a lot more money
probably in property than you would be
in a normal
day job so be inspired by logan paul
be inspired by floyd mayweather you can
stand with the giants
but work hard train hard and have bags
of belief
so thanks logan and floyd for putting on
a great fight it was very entertaining
people are saying it was staged lots of
people said i think it was a stage i
think it was
it's like sometimes people are so
skeptical of everything as well i mean
do i think it was staged i didn't think
it was stage i think if it was staged
um i don't think it would it would have
panned out the way that it did and the
guys that were saying at the stage they
were saying
oh it's what's gonna happen is logan is
gonna get his ass
worked to floyd and then jake is gonna
battle tommy fury
and then jake is gonna challenge fallen
and i didn't that's not what panned out
at all
actually logan held his own so and
people have said that about me as well
my financial freedom challenges it must
be staged it's too good to be true
you know someone recently told me that
no money down deals no money down deals
don't exist and then what do they do
then they save their money and put it
safely in the bank for the bank to use
their money to buy a property so that's
what that's called a no money down deal
just being done with their money by the
bank so don't be too skeptical
just be inspired go kick some ass have a
fabulous monday night
[Music]
peace
you